There is the Parliament,
there is the European Council
with the Council of Ministers,
there is the European Commission.
All the institutions have to
cooperate and collaborate.
My name is Martin Schulz. I am the
President of the European Parliament.
My name is José Manuel Durao Barroso.
I'm President of
the European Commission.
I am Eleni Mavrou. I chair
the Justice and Home Affairs Council.
I chaired the Economic Council.
It is called ECOFIN.
I'm Herman Van Rompuy,
the President of the European Council
of the Heads of State or Government.
The European Council is
a European institution
comprising the Heads of State or
Government of the 27 Member States,
soon to be 28 Member States.
We meet four times a year.
More often during a crisis period,
six or seven times a year.
Together we must bring Europe back on
the path to structural growth and jobs.
In fact, we give the overall directions
of economic policy and foreign policy.
We are the ultimate
political institution.
The European Commission represents
the general European interest.
That is the way we see ourselves.
It is a unique institution
with its supranational nature.
We come from all our member states
but we are not representing
our governments or countries.
We are here to try to interpret,
to represent the general
common European interest.
It is the European Commission
that has the right,
and I could say also the duty,
to present proposals for legislation.
Afterwards the Council,
where the governments are represented,
and the Parliament, approve them.
They are the co–legislators.
But the right of initiative
is the Commission's.
The Council of Ministers
meets in various formations.
It is the house
of the 27 Member States.
It is where ministers
from each country meet.
In each case, the ministers responsible
for specific fields take part.
And when a compromise is made,
on the basis of a proposal
from the Commission,
we will negotiate with
the European Parliament.
The Parliament represents
the citizens of the EU.
Here the people need to be
in constant dialogue with each other.
We are, above all, the only
legislative chamber in the world
that makes binding laws
for 27 countries and nations.
Who is in favour?
Who is against?
Who abstains?
It is approved.
We are a parliament with more than
700 members in 7 political groups,
which, I think, represent
a total of 300 parties
and accommodating them all
is a huge challenge,
but it's also a symbol of
what is fascinating about Europe,
namely being different
and, at the same time, being united.
I would say my role
is that of President
but also that of a facilitator.
Someone who has to act in such a way
that agreement is ultimately reached,
because each European Council has to
reach an agreement, reach a compromise.
You have to be well prepared
so that each European Council
is a productive Council.
There is a political will to break some
taboos and to find an agreement finally.
If only one person doesn't agree,
there is no agreement.
And so, at lots of meetings we've had,
I've had to find a very special solution
for just one country.
The President of the European Parliament
coordinates all the Parliament's tasks.
When I chair the plenary
I oversee everything.
It is not easy to keep eye contact
with so many members.
Colleagues, please listen a moment.
I think we need to be clear
on one thing regarding this house.
This house is a democratic institution!
Myself I have to confess,
it is sometimes hard to hold back.
I would like to take part in the
discussions because I am a politician,
but the President must remain neutral.
The role of the President
is, of course,
to give the overall political direction
and afterwards to work for consensus.
In terms of my daily work
I spend a lot of time working with
the other Commissioners.
I also need time to
represent the European Union,
at summits, with the
President of the European Council,
from the United States,
to China, to Russia, to India,
to Japan and the other summits.
Which is a real structural solution
to this crisis
while we receive nothing at all.
This can't go on.
Montesquieu is turning in his grave.
Parliament should reflect
the reality of society
and in society it is also noisy.
People are noisy too.
Go to a pub, go to a bistro
and listen to a political discussion.
That is also noisy,
there are also conflicts.
The European Council operates behind
closed doors, that's a huge difference,
because we can talk to each other
face–to–face and openly.
But I was surprised the first time I
took part as Belgian Prime Minister
that everyone was on first name terms.
I suddenly had to say Nicolas,
Angela, they called me Herman.
It's quite a strange experience.
But I saw there really is a team spirit.
You have personal contact
with each member of the Council.
Knowing the background
of each one's position is important.
I think it is very important that
you hear what other people say.
That you really listen.
Not just give them the floor
and say thank you,
but you really listen.
Understanding the other's position
is a key element in reaching decisions
on a European level.
What I see here is great independence
and dedication to the European cause.
My experience is,
and I think this is interesting,
that ideological differences
don't count in the European Commission.
I can say they are almost irrelevant.
Myself, I say that as President of
the Commission my party is Europe.
And I really mean it.
That is my party.
In the 21st century
identity and security
cannot be defended
only via national structures.
You need a power that goes further
than the national level.
And this power must be Europe.
The European Union
is not just about the market,
it is a project of peace and also
a project of freedom and democracy.
I think, more than ever in the 21st
century with a globalised world,
it is important that we stand together.
We are the first generation
that has not experienced war.
And this is a legacy we should pass on
to our children and grandchildren
that is why we fight hard
for Europe.
Not just for economic and monetary
reasons, as important as they are.
We fight also
to keep this European idea intact.